this video is brought to you by better
help more on them after the
reaction citizens of the reject Nation
it is time to be dawned in purple or
whatever I could have thought it this is
why you should have done the intros
today oh hold that up I do have purple
clothes I should have just worn a purple
clo anyway guys we're going to watch The
Color Purple the new one and I'm joined
with Roxy strier today I did a reaction
to the uh original one that Spielberg
made but that is not a musical I don't
know how you can make a musical out of
this but apparently the Broadway thing
is good did you see the original you can
make a musical out of anything are you
kidding they made a musical out of a
play about
AIDS okay well I'm working on my
Schindler's List musical you could you
could be catchy there's been
crazier I don't know about
crazier this is going to be good this
good intro it's going to be good anyway
guys uh what did you think about this
one do you prefer it over the 19
whatever one that came out leave your
thoughts down below a lot of people said
it was the best movie of the year really
yeah I'm hearing on so many people's
list number one of the year have you not
heard that no have you heard the word
the takis are saying you live under a
rock
bro I'm I'm glad I'm doing this one with
you leave a
like
subscribe and thanks to prepper for
editing down these highlights make sure
Roxy looks good in this reaction make
cut out all the ter thing she says also
full length Reaction watch along where
you single with your own copy of The
Color Purple catch all the Terrible
Things Roxy says available for our super
sexy Rejects at our patreon page what's
up my first hot take is that I actually
really like the color purple a lot of
people don't like it don't cut that out
prepper I like purple you're talking
about the color itself purple the color
purple how are you not leading the intro
and this is more derailed than
ever just want to let you know we're
watching the
movie
[Music]
a I love a good banjo tune that's what
you work out to sometimes it's a I've
been into like Dark Country lately in
dark Blues Country so this is amblin but
this is not uh Spielberg again right no
they actually got an I forget the
director but he's actually
African-American who made the
[Music]
movie he with you yes right song is the
original play games yeah you any good
can't say I
am what a cool establishing opening shot
from the banjo to tr track to
them it's always crazy how it this is is
going to be the dumbest comment ever but
in 1909 Ocean looks the same like you
you never would know Beach looks the
same nature always looks the same people
look different that is a good
comment okay
[Music]
okay I am loving the tune so
far oh my God way better than the
spilberg one
[Music]
oh helling The
Pastels Noah's Arc yeah she's doing the
Bible
[Applause]
stories man dancing in these costumes
looks
[Music]
exhausting where do you think they shot
this a sound stage if it's a boy I'm the
name of Adam like in the Bible get here
yes oh this is so moving of
know no way he's in
this WOW his voice is
[Music]
Stellar good Lord I've never been to
church but I can imagine this what it's
like for all churches
[Music]
oh this is
[Applause]
great what a great visceral opening
number what is she thinking
about longing for what God has planned
for her sacrifices the cross she had to
Bear the girl was floating above the
ground but she wasn't flying yet she got
nervous that the overseer would catch
her and without fake she fell to the
ground
Hard Solid ass transition right there
give me your hand I want you to feel a
needle I want you to feel a claw feel it
yes Mom don't be scared don't be scared
it's a very fascinating watch for me cuz
it's so tonally different from the
original film which is oop another cool
transition I broke my water hold still
I'll get the mid Bo what a way to
explain that not my water broke I broke
my water I just need you to push one
more time whoopy whoopy Cameo I didn't
know she was going to be in this NE did
I it's a little boy there he is that's
actually so fantastic that they gave her
this rooll for the Cameo for reasons I
will not go
into you n that baby here had a boy Paul
and air I'll give him the guard same as
I did the other let me may had just one
more day with him so
tragic you think you killed my babies I
believe he give to God just like he say
but they might how come God don't give
him back it's really interesting cuz it
it keeps all the you know harrowing
Darkness from the story however they
have to have this like Fantastical
atmosphere at the same time difficult
tone to balance I think they're doing an
excellent job it's very sensory that
mean it's getting late girl let me give
you a ride home I nobody's girl but my M
and she did that's Coleman Domingo I
know the new
king you got some real pretty
[Music]
te
Lord
Moonlight night and he poetical too
that's a real pretty dress my sister
made
it pretty little feet I'm tomboy and I
likes to climb trees I got corns bunions
and blisters ain't nothing pretty up my
feet now leave me be I'm sure you have
really nice feet what's your Wiki feet
rating what's yours you actually have a
real one don't you five stars
congratulations thank you everyone look
it up please
[Music]
don't what gorgeous sets there this
director did a really good job of making
everything feel extremely lived in like
the the musical number feels like a way
they communicate I think it's the guy
that did Beyonce's music video the album
video you know what I'm talking about
ask your
mom silly get your hand back to
work there are harsher aspects they have
to steer away from though in order to
keep it as a
[Music]
musical
wow I'm totally going to be down
downloading this
[Music]
soundtrack oh this like the exact kind
of tunes I've been listening to
lately it's a bummer that musicals are
not performing well recently this movie
did well
[Music]
though
Stars the longing
[Music]
yeah oh is this such a cool
song damn all these backup dancers put
through the
ringer
[Music]
I told you Greg nature stays the same
yeah it's a Sound
Stage it's like fantasy escapism for
[Music]
her I'm digging the simple choreography
too that's just right on point well it
seems like everything's grounded in the
emotionality but to move in those
costumes is
rough yeah like the the way they use the
music to communicate the escapism
through imagination is really profound
like escape the abuse via her mind I
want to ask for your Net's hand net too
smart she going to be a school teacher
but I'll let you see later for a cow and
a couple of J homemade sin better work
hard like a man damn that was a fast
negotiation I want that then your
children ain't beating on you bad enough
hard but you'll come around hopefully or
they burn your house down Jesus where
that outside talking aart the devil mhm
follow me home from school today now I
can't get rid of him he sure look nice
for
devil it's the whole point of the devil
say he got three raggedy children at
home say his last wife was shot by some
man she was seeing on the side o he got
something on the side too a loose woman
named sh gab the tea is piping hot Greg
o who plays Avery I wants to be a loose
woman hey no today our teacher taught us
about a place called Africa she say
that's where our peoples is from
interesting how you would grow up not
even knowing that at this time she say
our mom has come from Queens over there
that means that we royalty
royalty back your thing ceely time for
you to leave you marry Mister what a
harsh time who mister the de devil wow
so none of these story points seem the
slightest familiar to you no I I'm it's
like comes in and waves you know I'm
like oh yeah keep your head held high
just like mom taught us it's more like I
can't keep my eyes off hi Bailey oh she
is a captivating performance just like
so unbelievably engaging even if we have
to part you and me must have one heart
oh so sweet and sister stories are my
like so
so so the other film they age up and
they get different actors you know see
eventually becomes whoopy Goldberg are
they going to remain the same well I
know Taj is in this oh okay but I don't
know because what are they going to do
not have H Bailey in the movie yeah yeah
yeah exactly that's my point y'all come
down here and greet your new
mom that's
face you could uh get to cleaning and
then fix up a it's also they obviously
try to dress her differently but she's
very cute so it's funny when the like
when we're hearing she's uglier than sin
or whatever the dad said it's like
they're they're trying with the clothing
but she's very pretty
[Music]
face there's something about the tone of
this one that actually feels more
sincere to me even though there's a
musical element I like the other one it
did feel a little bit like spill made it
you know this food so good they got my
eyes watering I got to have
seconds when you want to give the Shing
bath it'll have to wait
tomorrow CG I didn't like that I'm glad
you said that otherwise the opposite
opinion i' be like oh this explains more
you're to notate that
moment
oh it's a Raji pan she plays Suge I just
saw hidden figures
[Music]
yesterday what is this on that it's
shaky the yeah that that I wish I didn't
ask they're actually not shying away
from certain
[Music]
things oh great
Paul tried to touch me I can't live
there no more E I really believe the
bond between these two yeah me
too where we going we got to get fir
with ph M come home we will but first we
got to have us some fun but net come on
want to be g a spell that hat is
unreal very very good costume design in
this movie
okay let's
[Music]
go love the frame of going down and
looking up yeah this is why casting
singers and musicals
[Music]
matters o just got
goosebumps break soul
what a great
line the nature looks the same as today
keeping a the only joy she feels right
now is with her
[Music]
cely all hats let's go
wild it's 100% not of sound sayage you
shot the S thing maybe it's TR in
Atlanta I have no idea I thought you
were joking when you said it was a sound
okay all right I meant it at first but
as the movies PR rest I'm like there's
no way this is a sound Sage may maybe
Parts I think the movie does a really
good job at letting the weather of each
scene affect the mood of the
scene oh
no
what a difficult balance to strike for a
film that is so I feel like you could
just be so in Conflict what you doing oh
I'm passing can't R my big doll you know
how I feel about you I don't
feel a out in the
[Music]
rain you okay that's the than thank you
for let
us my
leg what horrifying Darkness get off my
L you ain't never going to hit
again she come back here again I kill
you
both Greg we need a song right now
mhm I can't this is visually this is so
striking
too life can't break your soul
babe great illustration of how she is
now in the
[Music]
shadows it's like Twilight New
Moon oh clever then you could split the
screen with the
walls she aged up who's playing her so
many another day to
suffer what kind of are you tale of
Faith okay so it focuses more on
that okay so it's been eight years and
now we're in World War
I who's that I haven't seen Fantasia in
a long time but that's got to be that's
her okay anything comfor me what you ask
my things I don't belong to you fol that
mailbox is mine it's so difficult
because he is just like the most
charismatic likable seeming dude in in
life and here he's just like the you
want to murder him P bird Sophia I mean
don't you go no further I'm going I'mma
put my foot down Danielle Brooks I sat
next to her on an airplane once she was
singing Dream Girls out loud oh really
yeah
W Greg we're in our Dirty
30s yes we are it's going
swimmingly what's wrong with you girl
can't you read no fighting no killing no
women
woohoo yeah I love her well uh PA gry
jents I wants to introduce out to my
girl oh my God it's Cory Hawkins from uh
Straight Out of Compton oh yes Dr Dre Dr
Dre yeah I interviewed him
you seem like trouble no trouble at all
just big who the
daddy H how we know that hoo no that's
what matter see me and him we more than
the whims it's better than a radio show
man this good as
hell Petty guy like you can take his
mind but you can't have his money he
ain't got no
money now I come here out of
respect let's get on up and wait from
him come sugar d
by don't you move a muscle W there's so
much more Dynamics to have this scene
take place here at a bar instead of in
the private residence that girl ain't
welcome to my house PA she carrying my
child tough she ain't worthy of you you
barely know her I really like this
direction that he's taken to shoot a lot
of this like while it's Center there
looking up so that makes this whole
thing feel Larger than Life which I
think helps strike the balance hopo you
get my permission to build down here
what you get my permission to build down
here I'm building me a Sophia home on
you Carrying Your Brains in your back
pocket he made it this much and he
didn't notice until now yeah apparently
I'm building my woman a house P now you
can stay and help if you want and if not
well this conversation going to be
shorter than the time it took you to
walk down
here oh here we go this is come on so un
expected sometimes yeah but construction
makes a great
[Music]
yeah let's hear Dr
Dr these are the exact kind of tunes
I've been listening to so much lately I
love it what what do you mean what other
songs are you listening to it's kind of
like rhythmic sort of chanting drumming
kind of
sound it's like a dark Blues Country
kind Cory's voice is
fire oo this choreography is sick too
that's got to be hard to do with that
board he's making me want to do
construction mhm we got this so seamless
the way they go in it's so it's really
impressive nature looks the same Greg
yeah well even with that musical number
there wasn't like a bunch of instruments
the instruments all seemed like it was
like Acappella with the with everything
they had at their disposal at the
construction it really
impressive had sing it as the woman I
should have married sounds pretty it's
that kind of Tunes in Taylor Swift is
what I'm listening to
lately shut up and go to sleep like how
has she survived these eight
years having the performance of Danny
Glover fresh in my mind where he played
it more like a pathetic bumbling guy and
then Cola Domingo who's like such poison
strength blanket for the baby well don't
defeat the B hoo said you could do magic
with a needle but I do declare I do
declare and make us te I'm holding the
baby how supposed to hold the baby and
make tee I do it all the time women do
it man it's apparently Roxy does too I
don't know what baby she's holding I'm
the only person I know who doesn't have
a baby all my friends have babies how
come you so nice when the rest of hot K
so mean sirly I fig maybe you too nice
you must ain't got no K folk around
these parts only K folk I had was my
sister and I ain't seen her in years
that breaks my heart great reflection of
the lake oo thank
you how come the tea ain't
[Music]
hot you my hot tea give me
kiss know amazing
[Applause]
[Music]
she's such needed
light like none of this place is like
overly sentimental or sappy this is so
well done like that when they're doing
the drama drama scenes they work so well
and then when they're doing the musical
numbers it's it's really surprised by
how strong this is I take it you and
Miss Sophia having a rough honeymon
she'd be bidding the [__] out of him
maybe she ain't a jumping woman yep not
all of us are you think you belong in
that category not every woman's a
jumping woman yeah okay
Roxy you think I jump when a man says
so what I'm going to do beat her beat
her you told hoo to beat me no man you a
damn lie I didn't mean it then why'd you
fix your mouth to say it yeah I say it
cuz I I'm jealous of you you do what I
can't you fight oh that is so sad I'll
kill him dead before I let him or
anybody beat me all my life God damn how
do they do that had to fight
Brothers strength man never never never
never never thought i' have to fight in
my
own have I mentioned these are the kind
of tunes I've been listening to sorry
for you to tell you
yeah oh
[Music]
God and that's why she's not that
word just that emotion the
[Music]
singing oh my God this song is
incredible look at the inspiration
here hell yeah you better learn how to
fight back while you still
alive
[Music]
man hell
no she must have had so much fun with
[Music]
this who who is she she's incredible
Daniel Brook she's amazing I don't know
her yeah she's amazing but he tried to
make
mind I'm not kidding you on the plane
top of her lung singing dream girls
watching it for the first time I don't
know if it was the first time but she
was like oh I love this I was like
that's
[Music]
amazing walk out on
him you're a one hit wonder now
harpa you
[Music]
are hey
oh [__] I'd be so scared kick my ass oh
hell yeah that was
Unreal cuz they're not they're not just
hitting notes you know and they're
singing they're really doing a full like
line delivery in the emotion is there so
it blends perfectly when they're just D
me dialogue scenes the songs are really
well written too though no no I was just
a kick by mule was this mule wearing a
dress what you need to do with that home
you built is turned into a smok house
you me gr with tobacco yeah well maybe I
was uh me to say that this whole time
maybe I turn it into a juke joint don't
no matter want dance by no smelly swamp
notless sugar a sing that's a good
idea 1922 okay so five years
after what do we got going on
now
Batman mhm re husman I think he was
right about these being the last days
all things to be right about of all
things to be right about Su ay God help
me that's my daughter how did Paul how
you be I love that introduction God help
me that's my
daughter my
[Music]
man oh all the Moon
swooning
what a star does she have an amazing
voice about to find
out wish people would do this when I
come into
town they've kept their dance numbers
pretty small so far in terms of the
amount of people this is like the Whole
Town's coming out for sh
yeah Roxy I love this movie yeah I told
you a lot of people say it's was the
best of the year I I really love this
film are you a musical guy I've becoming
more of a musical guy a million
questions what she wear how her hair is
she skinny is she sty how to emulate
well imagine sleeping next to somebody
who's sleeping next to that every
night
Ain just no regard for how she
feels nope oh God hey s here what's
wrong with nothing she just gets thirsty
and like to drank a little sure
sure Hot Nuts Hot Nuts I got to take
that line Hot
[Music]
Nuts I do feel like we haven't really
been spending much time with cely though
which is the one thing that I'm kind of
craving huh didn't I say I wasn't
[Music]
hungry damn what a goodl looking meal
yeah yeah and we've heard she's an
amazing
cook she ate the whole thing she must
have been hungry well the food was that
good hello I'm a giggle
water right away baby imagine all these
years living in a domestically violent
home like that and he lights up and
treats this woman with just such rency
such such praise I need somebody to wash
my
b
what an honor that would be the light
coming and makes it look like when she
was with her mom good
[Music]
catch back in the fantasy
again wow what a set yeah that's sick
holy [__]
sickon
tingles sneaking on up my spine hm m
[Music]
i how
expressive yeah sexy oh hell
[Music]
yeah wow two completely different sh a
songs back to back one's more like an
intimate
sexual
[Music]
One godamn S you ug that's the line in
the movie really yeah I don't remember
that she said that I wasn't just saying
just be like she's an ugly
person when everyone else gets a musical
number it is an expression of how they
already are but when you go to want of C
Le it's what's who she is internally how
long you and I been a thing you're
trying to tell me you don't know your
own husband's name oh my God I thought
his name was Mister Mister ain't no name
it's a title just another way to say
master if you ask me that man can't even
stand up to his own Daddy but got
everybody calling him mister I was
wondering if the dad was going to be in
this that man get the high
stepping how come you don't laugh now
you know if you ain't going to laugh you
need to sell your funny
bone ain't you got something to make you
hop out of bed every morning and just
smile her sister I had too and I'm not
sure if they're alive or where they are
when you think about them does your
heart get full like the first time you
healed yes ma'am what didn't they still
alive that's Nature's Way of telephone
it what a sweet sentiment when I get to
thinking about him and how he used to
sing to me how come you just don't go
and visit him he Liv Just sh about the
church I think he lives at the church he
ain't forget gave me for choosing the
blues over his religion if God
understands why I say the BL maybe one
day my paw will her dad seemed pretty
understanding he is not I don't remember
I don't think he was participating in
the song and dance
number he's really moving them hips
right there
[Music]
yeah the color purple you ain't get the
head to understand I ain't never stop
Ling her woman's
cursed you ain't seen those Robins
covering the Sky last
week just when she arrived you know how
I feel about
liquid I sweetened it for you you want
if you women in this town allow your
husband's whole to sleep in your bed
spreading legs Daddy but why is she
spitting in his water he's standing up
for
her no Greg I can't I actually can't
watch that oh my
God tell me what's done is it done is it
done it's now
done I think in the thumbnail I'm going
to have it your grossed out face so it
could be very misleading how do you feel
about the movie I feel sick right now oh
my God Greg it's okay it's okay he
chugged it he chugged the whole thing oh
my God and he said this is the best
taste in water ever stop stop
stop you saying God is vain no not vain
Miss sely God just wants to share a good
thing oh but she didn't like that he was
calling her that's why cuz she loves her
I understand you saying God wants to be
loved like they say in the Bible oh
everything and everybody wants to be
loved especially God that's why God be
in everything yep you see God is in
music the water he be as big as the son
got to love God if God love me then why
he take my babies and why you take my
neck Lord works in mysterious ways sound
like men did that yeah that's that's the
point there you go it's actually a well
I'm glad that line exists there some
people blame God for things it's good
accountability line we open it Friday
night think you might like to come and
sign a little I got some voice too
this's my girl squeak you do not seem
confident in your girl squeak B it's
going to be ready for me to sign come
Friday oh yes that's uh that's her it is
her why are you laughing at it's her
what does what does her mean that's her
name her she's a singer
oh really yeah we could have gone back
and forth for a very long time she's
very popular with the kids her name is
her h r h do. r okay I saw her post
about being in this I think I mean they
they like pulled out all the
stops where's our Oprah Cameo are we
getting one I don't know I think it's we
she produced it so I'd hope so you said
you rolled your oh that's her
love it I'm telling you she coming to
H yeah we don't want to just toss to the
ground that's kind of
irresponsible oh my God I so badly want
to see her in that put it on you going
to be my guest tonight we need to look
like we belong what a power position for
her to be in well that's not
her see how it's confusing Roxy she look
say us G head so she want to make an
entrance oh she's making an
entrance oh my God oh my God oh my God
costume design like wo wow and I'm so
ready for this song what are we about to
get it better be the most amazing song
it's going to you can tell right
now all ladies know SH now to light your
on fire
got yeah
[Music]
girl
shook you got my
[Music]
attention I mean this is 1920s I'm
listening this is good advice
[Applause]
[Music]
wow
yeah a fun song hell
yes oh
nice oh my God this is getter and hotter
that was so Cell Block Tango whoa did
you see what he just did
yeah oh look oh this this business is
going to be a
booming Now ladies I need you to work a
little harder
okay push the
but push the
button do you think her dad's there no D
what you got to do you got to push the
button the
Buton that was a hot song so what I
don't remember what happens in the
original she comes and what happened
well the movie is going to unfold and
you will in this in the original what
like happened no actually in the in the
original she she does have like a
musical number number right okay but
she's just performing at a microphone
nothing about I don't know what it's
like I don't know what it's like in the
book though that was great that was an
amazing song excellent Barry kyogen Peri
of blood hottest things of the year
right there should you be at home taking
care of your baby shouldn't you be
somewhere with folks your age like a
cemetery I tell you I come in peace I
don't want no mess
Miss well speaking of No Mess G around
with another man when you still married
to me raising his children too he got
four miles to feed six if you can I new
baby this is a complicated time sorry I
got us off on the wrong foot come
on
I'mma still a for just one minute
careful oh yeah I'm going be
careful I don't know if I'd be
comfortable with that I want to dance
Too fine with me oh no no no this used
to be your house you ain't got to go
nowhere the level of disrespect here I
know with me don't touch me you snagle
too
heer oh my
God take down your prize fighter oh
[__] as much as I'd like to stay Memphis
is called I got to remind these folks
I'm still alive in the big city a I
ain't ready for you to leave miss the
much ni so when you here he don't beat
me as mon beat you why I do that come on
you didn't know you got to try where we
gone it's time for you to see the world
what is what does that mean they're not
going far just far enough to have a song
together or something enjoy the show
thank you what are they going to see
they try to take a sinere guess here
well we're in 22 and I don't know a
single thing as
Fatu oh this is like a classic movie
moment Swept Away by the escapism of
Cinema
this looks like an original film I
wonder what this is somebody tell us no
I I think this is like a thing they shot
for the movie no way we are in it right
now
now I'm pretty sure it's always has
[Music]
no a makes her feel like a star floting
we got some of that film
reel it's like art deco very cool
[Music]
design wow this is so
expensive you're not flipping the bill
for it
Greg feels like
it this isn't the renovations on your
house looks so so expensive looks like
so much
money
[Music]
about it's like she sees her sister in
her or something you know it's uh I
don't no what I don't think that's the
case you don't think she sees that like
the care carefreeness of her sister
she's 100% attracted to her you think
she's into her 100% for sure I think
that too okay I think it's kind of both
I know that's a weird thing to say but
just like misses the qualities of
somebody who's fun and yeah I go
[Music]
s I think it's multi layered like that
yeah I wonder if the people on
the oh yeah she's not looking at or is
her sister she thinking about her sister
right now she's right now she's thinking
about her sister I I don't remember any
part of this movie I really
don't I wonder if those people behind
the instruments were the actual
musicians maybe like actually let in
front of the camera that'd be pretty
cool Albert around oh no he probably
somewhere passed out I'll take the meal
take care now oh it's a sister writes
her every day and she's getting the
letter s
yes it's from her her your not her the
singer oh her her sister NY de I hope
this reaches you asz I've been writing
you every week for years I suppose you
didn't get out of my letters because you
haven't R back a that persistence to
keep writing you probably won't get this
either because Mister is still probably
the only only one who takes mail from
the box but if you do get this I want
you to know I love you and I'm not dead
I don't understand why Suge would would
be so attra so attracted to Albert I've
never have got that because he treats
her but I don't think it's but everyone
treats her like she's a God yeah but I
don't think she's specifically attracted
to him right it's just like she's 100%
she she always she stays with him she
gravitates towards him yeah but then she
leaves she doesn't stay long yeah
they're going to find all the
letters even there the like just right
there available not even hidden well
there'd be that just that much control
with fear that she couldn't even just
move the gun to check you know probably
wouldn't want to touch it all these
years I want to cry for
her but now what's going to happen he's
going to know know the letters are gone
I got a job working for a past across
town I helped take care of their babies
for food and shelter they told me they
were going to Africa as a missionary the
r told me he and his wife couldn't bear
children God sent them too they showed
me the name you had sewn on the baby M
and I knew the babies were yours it's a
miracle godamn miracle man they were
n ooh cool shoulder movements we are
more than just kings and queens we are
at the Center the
universe Nature's the same Greg it is
the amount of like cultural and
Community application they have done
throughout this entire film is wild it's
interesting that he saved all these
letters it's
true and this movie done such a good job
at establishing Her Imagination that
this expressiveness just makes so much
exactly I have faith that God will let
us see each other before we die I only
hope when that day comes oh doesn't one
of her kids die or something I made that
up don't tell me I don't know I'm
sad no why Su late he's right back to
being miserable all you got to do is
cook and clean and you can't even do
that I do better that's what your mouth
say if I got to eat late you won't eat
it all but he's so likable in
euphoria you know hey who is he in
Euphoria uh Zena's sponsor I forgot or
he's Jacob Alli he's one of the he is
Jacob oh can I have two vanilla ice
cream are those yours ice ice they so
chocolate I could just eat them up
yikes you should come be my
maid I'm Miss Millie the mayor's wife if
not just ask around the colored love
I'll pay you fair I believe I'm not
racist I'm talking to you gal you wants
to be my maid or not is it a real offer
where she can choose hell no hell no
what's that you say to my wife I said
hell no oh no oh no oh no come on Sophia
just get in the car no no no
no don't let him see
oh God Greg I didn't like that how you
been know this this is the role that
Oprah played and I feel like she
completely delivers too you know Sheriff
say I could bring you a plate for
Thanksgiving you say you ain't a in day
that's why you wrote Thanksgiving in our
calendar yeah the audience knows exactly
what you're talking about and then
Buster he help out every now then though
I feel the incident broke him but ho
love his kids like de oh God I'm going
to get you out of here that's my I said
time to go don't leave me oh no Craig
don't leave me she was like the whole
light of the movie it's the first time
we've seen her beg plead first time
we've seen her feel like a position of
feeling
[Music]
weak yeah the power shot every time
it's like a classic production of
this she's
[Music]
Rising oh
Goosebumps the passing of the times they
do Through the Windows and now she's
getting kind of the experience of cel's
Journey this like complete
[Music]
isolation oh
no oh it's a lot of time oh boy I have
agreed to allow her to live and work for
me till she's back on her
feet oh no mayor's wife is so much more
obviously a villain this time let's not
Dole just got out no time
sop I made this for
you there's a lot of characters in this
movie yeah it's an epic epic drama like
I give a crap about every single one of
them I thought I told you not to touch
the
mail sh's coming shly come shave
me whoa I thought you hadit a machete
for a second what the
hell Ste get the molasses out your ass
what I really appreciate too is that for
a musical sound design obviously
important but they let the sound pop on
a whole bunch of other things
too you do know what happens right
now I don't think I can watch Greg oh no
is she no no
what fine okay okay okay okay okay Miss
CE we married ladies now come on what
you got to eat oh man I actually forgot
about that the guy showed her showed up
with the guy me and gr can't stay yeah
we got to get on the road for grd got to
get back to work come on we taking sely
with us ain't that
right it's time she saw more of this
world I died before I let that happen
good
oh hey watch yourself you better handle
your woman she she didn't found M she
just being stupid what's gotten into you
dummy I done had enough it's time I be
free from you and enter into
creation you took my sister nety away
from me is and my cheing with netti and
AF us all together we going to whoop
your country ass your mouth of my house
well it's about time to load the
luggage he ain't nothing but a sack of
dead H [__] and hor [__] belong in the
ground
she call him a sack of dead
[Laughter]
hor I love a moment in a movie where
it's like enough's enough just
done I want to thank you Miss s uh I was
feeling byy bed riding in that prison s
but you came and see by me every week
wow
that's how I know God
whoa cuz he's living in you the wom at
this table have lost Dem
mind I wants to go to Memphis too oh
come on that's Squeak My Name ain't
squeak it's Mary Agnes that is her is
her all you fit to do is clean a slap
jaw and cook a food he ain't even that
could a cook until you do right by me
everything you think about going C curse
whoa you're poor you're ugly you a woman
I should have kept you under my shoe
like the rot you is everything done to
me mhm I may be poor I may even be ugly
but I'm
here it's really interesting cuz there's
like things that are cut out to make
room for the musical numbers there's a
lot there's like so much other stuff
dramatic things in between like some
real harrowing [__] that they completely
skip over like what like a lot of what
happens with Sophia post jail and then
the work and stuff like they skip over a
lot like this stuff kind of comes later
I ain't never had my own room before I
probably wouldn't even know how to
act like the way this is like ramping up
is like World War II post okay so now
we've gone we span a lot of time started
what in
1908 oh no the crop has failed oh
they're about to go po because the bugs
is that what's happening Greg beetles
huh beetles oh no oh no it's him cuz the
curse oh good Superstition
[Applause]
now it's like a Biblical
plague yeah every time we cut to like a
few years later it's like we we shorten
the gap of the runtime on it so there's
like a good ramping up
[Music]
ooh get it she is unbelievably like sexy
magnetizing in this
yeah oh yes we got the
song See sister look at each other like
sisters G yeah sisters you make out with
that's not what you do with your sister
oh shut up don't even let my mind go
there
[Music]
sing he's
funny they have a lot of songs you know
some musicals I feel like at this point
musical movies steer away from it
because they're nervous to fully load
but this is a fullblown musical oh wa
cuz honey the
sh is feeling f
[Music]
yeah I believe at the bar that's what
she performed in the other movie that
song miss you got a call don't know but
sounds urgent it's Oprah evening this
wow they're going to make us guess you
already know it's Oprah it's her
yeah did he
die no she wouldn't be looking sad then
something got of sister or her
kids sweet loving God we thank you for
the life of Mr Alonso M heard that I got
that when we saw the picture I hope
so and I'd be a lie if I told you for
certain that Mr Alonso made it to the
Pearly gate this is a hell of a funeral
we must forgive and ask forgiveness from
others H so don't te your church no one
knows what day what hour we will see our
father amen amen sure that's a hard dad
to forgive sold off his daughters and
[__] man yeah but he was really just now
preaching to his
daughter and she said amen oh yeah I
toally forgot about that for real yeah I
got you good at least I added a little
value
today yeah really enjoyed your sermon
Paul especially what what you said about
forgiveness ain't the time right now re
bu you got to practice what you preach
and not everyone can do that literally
Practice What You Preach what's this for
place is yours what has she been in he
didn't leave it to you no ma'am it
wasn't his to give you didn't know we
w't quite UNS speaking to her she gets
to have the store huh well when I went
to settle alonso's will I found out from
the lawyer that this wasn't his land nor
his Stone your real Paul built this
place Alonso was my P oh man' when your
daddy died your Mom married
Alonso fonso took over the store I don't
remember any of this your real daddy
even put you and your sister's name on
the deed wow I and a love oh my God a
damn that was a real shedding of tears
right
there she's fantastic I wonder if she's
been working since American Idol and I
just haven't seen get at burying her
soul she's not afraid to be no like very
vulnerable doesn't seem to care at all
about how unbelievably challenging role
to play too M I got out house oh now
what's I going to
do I'm nervous about colan Domingo
though feel a needle feel it I want you
to feel a claw she going become a
seamstress
maybe you know I'm I'm a seamstress
really yeah thanks for all the stuff
you've knitted for me what do you
want my
face
oh my God it's not a fantasy it's really
happening her outfit is killer and now
she's in red that's the power color
let's go
baby remember when when taji was in red
the center of attention with the fur
yeah now she's giving main character
energy visual
storytelling out
m and man might have
done
[Laughter]
[Music]
you and made you believe that you're not
strong
yes oh [__] oh yeah you're right great
call Roxy on everything there
[Music]
cute laugh I need sister time it's
really great how like the musical
numbers complement the drama instead of
detracting from it you
know I'm over his is he's very
frustrating guy you embarrass
yourself
how'd she do the
curse
yeah get
up Coca-Cola still managed to advertise
in this life is good
coca-c I have my DS how about you
building that jeice what you done good
boy oh everyone still wants their
parents' approvals yeah it's hard it's
really hard to get it especially when
our parents are are dead yeah
dpcs why you guys around me oh my God I
get home by
myself wow cue the thunderous rainstorm
I get home by myself this is the most
overwrought situation you could be in I
feel like these are some of the hardest
scenes to perform because you have to so
over exaggerate but still look
believable until you do f
everything you think about going crumble
until you do right by her yeah here's
this more Fantastical quality that kind
of just has a breath over the whole film
I fell asleep looking at the stars as
all you take care of yourself here they
got down in the mud man what is oh it's
going to be the sister and he's going to
bring it to her because he's doing right
by her dear cely the letters you sent
fill my days with joy no so farfetched
the British have seized the East we lost
our passports and documentation when our
village was burned I've decided it's
best that me and your children make our
way back home to you he's not going to
tell her no that's wrong immigration
office to prove our citizenship you're
our only hope he's going to prevent her
from coming into the states no even if
we could find them which I doubt it'll
cost you hundreds to get them here from
Africa well uh I thanks you mhm say uh I
got me some land mhm I could sell some
of it and get the money my secretary
didn't start the
paperwork we're close it's not going to
go the way you think really really just
Ming this going to sound odd but uh I
came to buy some pants I can come back
later of his too much trouble wow he's
being very polite yeah cuz the world
handed him his butt you see something
you like well I don't just take one of
the ones that no one else buys help your
business out so you looking nice you
sure you want to be seen in these I
don't mind gift book something to laugh
at I best be locking up damn he could be
really Charming huh that's what I'm
saying maybe someday uh you and me we
could uh I don't know if uh if you feel
like it sometime let's just us be
friend
wow so maybe in that moment he felt like
it was lifted
already like she got to change and help
so many people's lives by just
continuing to be a good person no matter
what happened the only bad thing we ever
saw her do is tell somebody to beat
their wife and then she immediately
admitted because she was jealous yeah so
it's really not that bad what she said
to do
[Music]
I love his still Hal
Bailey now may not be
[Music]
here so hard to shoot mirror shots and
hide the camera as well as they're doing
with all of that really great work and
the fact that she's like look at herself
accepting of herself more and
[Music]
more I'm going to put
my back and look you stra in the that
was a reminder to correct your
[Music]
posture
oh yeah embrace yourself me yeah
[Music]
you
man the conference of everything yeah
this is such a
moment oh hell yeah what a great
self-acceptance I'm
beautiful wow to just say that I'm
beautiful
[Music]
I'm oh that is such a hard thing for to
say
I'm
a and they talk a lot about self
validation in this world and it's really
difficult for people to just actually
utter the words to self validate
themselves
and to say something like I am beautiful
is a can be very uncomfortable for
people not for me though I'm really good
at
it this is the shortest time jump from
45 to 47 damn it's been like 40 years
holy
[Music]
[__] she has not forgotten her Roots
yeah but the dad owes her an apolog olog
she was following her heart her
passion she wants nothing more than to
make amends
with what a moment maybe it's this
relationship why she was drawn to
[Music]
Albert is always at this church he lives
well they said he doesn't live here but
he
does don't really need to say much else
we get
it o cool what a
centerpiece I know this haunting tree
the Sun the use of the sunlight and all
this is so wild because it does have
that God effect to it being in
everything put my
inants for those I ask I used to beat
the [__] out of her and now we're
friends damn I thought I invit a few
folks oh my god oh no Craig oh my God
it's going to be her sister I
can't hey S no
[Music]
a
ladies mhm whoa that's
Sierra
a
[Music]
oh yes
sisters these are your children oh no
oh she deserves this moment so
much wow it it does it is
us we love
you oh
[Laughter]
no this is my wife
AB no yeah there whole
family you have grandchildren
[Music]
oh oh in the sunlight the way I was like
her mom earlier in
story but there's still time in the
movie and I think it needs to end cuz
what good can happen from here is it
going to be bad
[Music]
Greg hello I think Coleman Domingo slaps
the [__] out of all no don't
even my family oh thank goodness taj's
outfit is
[Music]
sick can you get over that who they got
to play
her I don't know who that is RO I told
you it's
Sierra you know who that is this beat is
automatic supersonic hypnotic funky
fresh yeah I want to hear that right
while I'm
listening
C God is
oh my God
Greg screw this movie I'm
done well she we're gonna have to hear
[Music]
her I'm
done blade
[Music]
of the color palette in this shut the
front door
bro I do not forgive Coleman Domingo
this is a good thing he did and it's
important to do every day you have the
opportunity to be the best version of
you and he picked that one time but I
don't forgive him and I know this movie
is about forgiveness and it's telling us
to forgive but I don't forgive him what
hatred do you have in your
[Music]
heart Craig that's
Sierra let me see you one to
step
[Music]
okay men Faith a men bro now in the
credits role they're going to play let
me see you one two step I love it when
you Greg we're still so far from that
moment what else could happen only bad
from here if somebody else dies I'm
pretty sure he going to say directed by
in like a second oh good thank goodness
Greg
what what this is so funny you're a
funny
person that was like emotional
torture
you must be new to the
channel this is a core quilt
thing I've made
many what we're listen a song well just
like medium
volume yeah it's good it's good Greg I
feel like you just beat the crap out of
me man you ain't seen nothing on this
channel I have ugly cried like a mofo
here
before you're okay Roxy you're okay my
friend I don't I feel okay cuz you have
a sister you love and you miss I do and
she's in Africa right now and you want
to be GRE
out why do you forgive Coleman Domingo I
don't forgive
de why do youa you did an unreal job
with that choreography bro you POS such
leading questions sometimes yeah because
you said that I had hatred in my heart
for not forgiving him well okay taji
taji held her own in this movie Brook
star
stud Coleman Domingo unreal in this
movie Corey Hawkins a true legend Dr
Dre
her her I told you hie Bailey I wish we
got a flashback of her at the end I know
they really should have milked that yeah
she's so
good but is it gonna say Sierra Sierra
bro it's
Sierra that's crazy that they got Sierra
in
this I mean obviously they have huge
stars in this but like just for the last
scene Sierra comes through Fantasia
burino thank you to better help for
sponsoring this video I've literally
just finished a therapy session and I
wanted to shoot this cuz I'm in this
state of knowing why I Champion mental
health support so much in the past few
weeks work's been a little bit hectic
it's led me to miss some sessions and I
really don't like doing that and
sometimes that's when the weight really
starts to pile on a lot of restless
nights a lot of fatigue a lot of I can't
sleep even though I'm so tired sometimes
just a very deep-seated sense of Gloom
meditating and sometimes journaling are
my daily go-tos but sometimes they just
don't cut it when I'm trying to pinpoint
why I'm down and really after a session
like today therapy just really helps
clear the fog discussing the feelings is
a critical step for me especially as
someone who's diagnosed with ADHD type 2
byar and PTSD it's truly a Cornerstone
of my well-being and I'm not alone in
this many of us here at real rejects are
in therapy facing our own challenges
from depression to anxiety or just
needing a non-judgmental space to voice
our thoughts this year I've been working
out most days of the week to keep my
physical health strong and I really do
Champion therapy as a way to strengthen
my mental resilience and for many better
help is integral to that process There's
real value in better help's accessible
in adaptable service they match you with
the licensed therapist and provide the
option to switch if necessary ensuring
the right fit for your mental health
Journey as this year winds down and we
confront life's complexities do consider
betterhelp as a resource really happy to
be partner with them this month so you
can go to betterhelp.com rejects for 10%
off your first month again that's bet t
r
hp.com slre rejects so join us and
moving forward stronger together thank
you again if you're listening to Apple
on Spotify we just watched the 2023
version of The Color Purple Roxy had
zero interest in watching this I had to
convince her it was it was a phone call
I had listening right now so they can't
see me rolling my eyes on Apple and
Spotify well I mean the rolling the eyes
is just an act that she's putting up to
make it seem exited to see she was
pushing against if you believe me give
us five
star um and I had seen the I know it's
based on a book and I had seen the other
film right here on this channel that
like there were the ending scene of the
the first movie there were two scenes
that made me really cry in the original
one like bald right here on this channel
and one was just the moment with whoopy
Goldberg like when she breaks into a
smile like a real smile when she's with
Suge did Wy Goldberg win for this I
don't I don't know actually and then the
the ending scene really did make me like
ball the last time around and so this
was like a different kind of viewing
experience for me than for you cuz I was
like watching
oh there's remake elements and I'm aware
of film making technician stuff and I'm
also seeing like what they trimmed and
I'm curious to see how they adapted so
it was like a different kind of lens
when the other one is fairly fresh in my
mind like it's a few months ago but it's
still fairly fresh in my mind so I had
kind of a oh I'm fascinated by this and
so I wasn't like quite moved to the
emotional Heights you were moved to by
the end there because a lot of this was
very fresh for you and new uh I I loved
the movie I like this more than the
original film and the original one while
was very much moved by I did feel was a
little sappy a little like I don't know
overly sentimental o Winfrey assistant
to
selberg it's amazing just who are they
who's
Winfrey I I still I thought that this
movie um just was vibrant had the
musical numbers are the exact kind of
jams I love to listen to and I thought
it helped really move the narrative and
the emotional experience forward as
opposed to pause take a break for the
music numbers and they Blended
seamlessly with the rest of the movie H
in a way that felt like it wasn't
detracting or taking attention away
because sometimes in I think musical
movies there has to be a way to
transition where it feels like it's a
part of the same world and they did that
here where I was never distracted by oh
we're going into a musical number right
now and somehow manag to balance tones
where you're dealing with like abuse um
assault and still make a fun movie out
of it I don't know how you do that they
managed to do it so yeah man that was
that was a really really exceptional
film to me and uh I do prefer it over
the other film I feel empty inside now
Greg why do you feel empty I don't
understand I don't know it was so such a
difficult watch for me it was oh my God
why I don't know it just was they
because they did a what they were
supposed to do right it felt like her
life was torture and then she finally
finds happiness and gets everything that
she always deserved because she stayed
true to herself as a beautiful person
and yeah you know life can't break your
soul but it breaks most of our souls and
if I were her it would have broken my
effing soul and it didn't and she stayed
the course and it was
just really a hard hard watch like they
threw in all these upbeat songs that
were amazing but I just feel like
depleted and sad and just like just so
effed up and then you know there's like
on the one side all's well that ends
well but on the other side it's not
about the destination it's about the
journey and oh my God she had like the
hardest journey and so I thought the
movie was a hard journey
yeah you're not wrong you're not at all
and I don't remember the first one and I
remember it being this sad oh my God it
is like so sad yeah but I think cuz I
watched it when I was little I think I
must have just not really like
understood the grasp of everything going
on you know like it's like it's like
watching Annie as a little kid and not
really realizing what the hell is
happening like you're just like
listening obviously that's this wasn't a
musical Z but like you don't know the
weight of things you're seeing something
and it's like you know it's a movie and
then I mean they're hard harer in the
other movie like it it goes it I'm sure
they were but I was a kid so it didn't
affect me the same yeah know I think
they have like a more disturbing
elements it's Bleaker it's sadder and
cuz it's it's nothing but trauma
basically this felt like nothing but
trauma for two hours oh but you got the
musical numbers which are so moving and
stuff amazing and I think that's
probably why like the drama will hit you
harder because I was like a it pretty
much follows the same beats like pretty
much and then there's like stuff
eliminated and then replaced with
Musical numbers and then certain scenes
happen in different locations and again
I'm only comparing this to the original
movie not the book I don't know the book
uh so yeah like I and I think a most of
us who I think a lot of people will
probably say like yeah I saw the movie
from spilberg but I didn't I didn't read
the book so I'm one of those people and
who wrote the book I have no idea what
when when was the book but it's it's is
I think it's a I mean a long time ago
but I think it's a very fascinating tale
to see the Legacy this specific story
has told because it's so much about
endurance self-acceptance love Faith and
you watch it go from book to film to
then Broadway musical to then getting
adapted like it's been such a journey
with this one tale yeah and uh with
characters that have just stood the test
of time and for for a story that doesn't
it's not a conventional tale you know
it's a very specific kind of story and
I'm I'm very wowed by
how even though I was I couldn't help
get the original the other movie Out of
My Mind only because of how fresh it's
been in there I was still very much more
I I I think in in in some ways even
though I I didn't cry like I did the
last one but that was because I was
aware of the plot beats and I had a
different kind of lens watching this I
still think that this movie was
sharper um it I the the voice behind the
camera I thought spoke louder volumes
and rang more true to the actual story
at hand it actually felt more sincere
and I weirdly say even though it's not
as Bleak it's a bleak experience but
it's not as Bleak it somehow feels more
authentic and I can't quite pinpoint
that even though it Embraces a FAS what
like the
reality authentic in the sense that I
don't feel any pretention behind the
camera on this one and I I looked it up
afterwards too with with with the other
film because like o Oprah is phenomenal
in it Danny Glover plays Coleman
Domingo's role he plays mister and uh
whoopy Goldberg uh is is incredible as
cely in that and I did look it up after
cuz I was like I have these thoughts and
okay a lot of people also kind of feel
this way too it is it's like oh it's
it's got it it felt spilberg made it
before Schindler's List and at the time
of him making that I'm just trying to
recall exactly what I said there was a
bit of a pretentiousness to it where it
feels like overly sappy and romantic the
drama I was I was trying to look up if
other people felt the same way oh oh oh
that it was
pretentious yeah yeah like you kind of
needed a I feel like you needed a black
director to make I I think you need a
black director to make the color purple
like someone who can kind of understand
some of this life in a way that doesn't
feel like wow look at me making a drama
you know yeah mhm like I don't think it
needs to be a black person like you're
saying you think that he could do it
with Schindler's List because he was
Jewish and doing see I don't even want
to like say that I didn't know what you
brought up Schindler's List for just I
was saying I think his his his attention
to detail and his and it uh his like
Schindler's List felt I Reed to that
movie here too broke my heart the there
that had a sense of authenticity it
didn't feel like a romanticized drama in
any way you know and but The Color
Purple did but the color purple feels
feels
like a a highly produced television
drama like a Hollywood Blockbuster I
would say a blockbuster it feels like a
like a television drama like a
television not made for TV movie yeah
but like with a big budget and and well
really really well done version but you
can't see past like that's interesting
how I personally felt about it even
though I was moved by the film
simultaneously uh and uh this to me
while bigger more of a scope more
variety has musical Fantastical
elements um I never got the feeling that
whoever directed this
was trying too hard in a way like like
oh you're overreaching like it always it
always whatever Heights they were
soaring for it always felt genuine
that's I think that's the word more I'm
looking for is that there was a constant
Genuine Voice to this interesting yeah I
don't have the same comparison thing
that you do um to know I don't know why
you would because this felt very
Fantastical to me but yeah yeah
definitely um but I think the voice of
the Fantastical inness is genuine you
know what's crazy is like I A lot of
times after a movie what was the movie
that we watched that um Final
Destination 4 no no the movie that we
watched where uh it's that girl on the
cover dead talk Dead with the talk to me
talk to me talk to me that's what it was
called and I was like I never want to
see that again it's how I kind of feel
about this movie I don't think you could
handle the original I love the music and
I would listen to this music all the
time I think this movie was so wellmade
and watching it was like a true
experience but I don't know that I could
do that again I feel like like I
honestly feel like crap right now wow
like I feel really really not good which
is wild because the end is like a
beautiful I was and it was like happy
tears at the end um but I just I I don't
know watching like people go through
pain and suffering for so many hours is
so
hard very hard yeah and I think uh
that's one of the beautiful things about
the color purple story is finding
finding um the love in the midst of such
hardship yeah and they sing about that
and like having to it's I just can't
believe there's so many people on the
planet who have to stay good when the
universe is giving them every reason to
not beautiful messaging unbelievable
lyrics incredible dancing it's a sister
movie it's like perfectly done and like
I can't function right now fully wow I
wasn't expecting you'd be so effed up
about it
oh that was good to smile for a second
good good I haven't smiled in two hours
and 33 minutes no but the end you know
it's like some movies have really
depressing endings and then you usually
walk away more upset this had a really
uplifting ending but like to get to that
point
man yeah
uh yeah that's and I actually didn't
quite think of it in that perspective
that you have of like my my depressed
I'm coming from like the like the really
heavy drama version that's in my mind
where they go like everything with
Sophia felt so much worse in the other
one and like the [__] that she endures
after after she gets out of uh out of
prison we see her at the mayor's wife's
place there's this whole thing where
like yeah where she's working for her
for a while like you really just stayed
in a lot more stuff for longer the uh
yeah I guess my mind was was wondering
and imagining how all that would be and
I just felt so bad for her too Daniel
Brooks is like a real star yeah whereas
like this has like this contrast where
like when the musical numbers would come
in I I was having like a really good
time yeah the the one musical number
that I there's a few that I was able to
have a really good time but the the Hal
Bailey sister walk one when we're still
early on before there's been some abuse
but not all of the abuse I was still
like feeling okay okay like the sisters
you know what I'm talking about yeah
yeah no I'm just trying to get into your
head a little bit here um it's okay so I
mean to me it sounds like your viewing
experience is also largely affected by
the fact that you do miss your sister
yeah yeah probably yeah it was
unfathomable to me like to watch this
and think about her being somewhere else
and not knowing that she was
alive and somebody else knowing that and
keeping that from you MH like I hate
him he's way worse than the
other I hate him I hate him for what he
did all the things he did I really
really hate him and he gets to be at the
dinner because he's wearing the pants
and I'm like I hate you I hate you yeah
he's not good to have in your heart Greg
in the other film he's um he's from afar
like he he helps from afar he's not like
this whole like gathered at the dinner
like I think it's kind of those like you
know nods of Repro was like H yeah I've
done good like I guess Redemption for
this guy yeah it's like it doesn't
forgive the things that you have done
but it is always good to choose to do
the right thing that was the right thing
to do it's better for him to do that
than to never do the right thing at all
wh well what I what I
liked if I if I can say one thing cuz
you know he's a man and we got to
forgive men when they're abusive that's
a good point you know I can say one
thing forgive all men if it's an exwife
or a lover of a famous man oh man may
they be burnt at the cross so Coleman
Domingo right MH uh when he goes I don't
remember if any this in the other story
but what I liked was this whole thing
when he feels the Superstition kicks in
he feels like he's like he's really
living in a curse right yeah
yeah that's what she does Cur and uh
when he's feeling them in the curse and
then it echoes in his head like oh okay
I got to do right by her my mind was
thinking I don't know how feel about
this if he's only going to do something
good to help himself out of the curse
yeah and and so what I liked about when
he he goes to visit her at the store he
doesn't tell her he doesn't tell her any
of this um and and and she makes her
peace with him there you know she says
let's just be friends like she makes she
makes her peace so he doesn't he didn't
have to go the extra mile he didn't have
to do this she's able to forgive him and
I'm just like girl how how are you this
amazing of a human I can't cuz that's
what women do yeah it's just
unbelievable though you know like he put
her through like as she said at the
table you he made her life a living hell
truly absolutely yeah I I thought that
was beautiful I mean to have a
protagonist that you root for as heavy
as you root for her is always strong and
I feel like maybe in a week if you ask
me about this movie I'll want to see it
again but right now it really feels like
somebody beat the crap out of
me and then gave me a cookie at the end
well also like but I still got the [__]
kicked out of me I mean also you really
You Took the Cookie from me in the
[__] first place if you're really
sure you're a woman and I'm not a woman
and I think a a woman watching this will
have a very different experience think a
black woman watching this have a very
different experience too like yeah that
that too I mean like we haven't even
spoken about any of the racial tones of
this which I thought think it was
interesting that you don't often watch a
movie where um we're going to like a a
time in our what did you say like the
yeah the 40 years Gap with no no I was
yes but we're going back in uh American
history and we're watching um the
treatment of black women versus black
men usually we're watching the treatment
of black people versus white people back
in the early 1900s um and so watching
like what people who have a little bit
of power but still are being kept down
by Society due to people who have even
less power than them that was really the
whole thing is upsetting man It's
upsetting It's upsetting what we do to
each other as human beings when when
there are people like uh Fant what's
what's the main character's name cely
like cely then there people like cely
who are like that's who should have
power in the world because she would do
good with it and when she does finally
get the shop she does she's doing good
and she's doing she does and it's like
that's never who has the power over
anybody else I don't know it's just
upsetting time to be alive yeah so did
you have any expectation of what is
ented remember I remember liking this
movie but do you remember like any any
difficulties with subject matter in it
CU it seems like that all is completely
left your brain you're like wow this is
a mean movie no no I remember it being a
serious drama but I didn't remember like
being affected like this I remember like
like I had more experience it happened
to me with a lot of kids that a lot of
movies I watch as a kid where as a kid
you kind of just like it's a movie yeah
yeah but and this is a movie it's not
like you know as a kid I would think
this is boring as [__] as a kid I would
think this is Bor I don't really
remember it that much I just remember
thinking that it was a drama I mean I
wasn't that I was probably like
10 and it probably probably affected me
a little bit but I since you know I have
a hard time remembering movies in
general so yeah it's yeah definitely
left my brain more than I thought well
definitely left my brain more than I
thought I remember being whoopy I loved
Whoopi I dressed um well I don't know
that's I loved whoopy so much I did a
class project on her and then I you
dress this her obviously not what you're
thinking but for school yeah I had like
a really cool jacket you think I was
thinking
what what did you think I was thinking
when I said I dress as Wy Goldberg I saw
you roll your eyes I didn't do anything
I didn't roll my eyes I went I went huh
yeah I like loved her as a kid she was
my idol and so I remember I must have
seen this and thought I don't know maybe
I was just paying more attention her I
don't know this was hilarious no I
didn't think that this just really
affected me uh I well on this movie I
didn't mean to I didn't mean to steer
this conversation into such a compar in
peace and uh I it's just hard for me not
to espe especially because I reacted to
the other one here a few a few months
ago um and with who by
myself I couldn't have done this by
myself there was actually moments in
this where I don't know if this might
have been the quietest I've ever been in
a
reaction pretty quiet I couldn't like I
couldn't like verbalize any of my
thoughts it was it was worried something
I was like she bored is that what you
thought I'm not like looking looking at
you here's to looking at you kid should
I just do that the whole reaction next
time next be like you're being kind of
quiet
Rox might want to speak up a little bit
toots I didn't like even know how to I
want you want you vocalize your thoughts
this man giving you permission to talk
good
good I'm going to be like Danielle Brook
you talk again I beat the [__] out of
you woman that was a good voice ha
I am Colman
Domingo well he became a pirate you did
you
went no it's the Takis I was doing what
you were doing you speak again and I'll
you're doing a pirate voice that's not a
pirate voice I'm doing the
Takis what that's oh okay the takis are
kind of like here the takis are kind of
like here like that what's a pirate
sound like I a pirate I a pirate matey
not bad I'm a pretty bad
pirate um yeah okay well we'll close us
out with this quick recap highlights uh
Hal Bailey excellent loved her musical
numbers thought the musical numbers were
phenomenal great choreography throughout
uh costumes if this is not going an
academy a war nomination I'll be
extremely disappointed in it for sure
for sure Daniel Brooks I thought was my
favorite performer honestly um so good
especially to following Oprah's footstep
like this movie made Oprah a star and to
following her footsteps I thought she
completely lived up to it uh taji P
Hensen excellent just the gravitas and
the magnetism as you said during the
reaction is so so accurate to it h so
many layers and uh Coleman
Domingo so I didn't speak during the
reaction good good yeah you said a
couple of words uh Coleman de yeah you
you recited the whole Sierra
song Let me see you thought of things to
say one St and uh uh yeah every everyone
was great the look was awesome I thought
there was so much Great Expression
Fantasia as C I mean she was excellent
performer that was the one hurdle I was
having a difficult subjective time
getting over was that granted whoopy
does not sing in the other one I was
very much I I actually
I had a hard time not comparing okay it
was CH and I understand that pisses
people off when you do that uh just got
to be honest with you all I had a hard
time like not comparing when it's doing
the same beats as the other film and
whoopy Goldberg that's a very iconic
portrayal for her I was I found myself
exceptionally more connected to to
Whoopi than I did uh with this
portrayal and I think I I think it has
something to do with because at one
point I even said to you like I feel
like we're not really seeing cely a lot
we kind of when you said that I was
thinking to myself I feel like we spent
a lot of time with her yeah and I think
that's where my brain was having a bit
of a hard time let like being aware of
we cut past like a lot of stuff a lot of
a lot of this follows the same beats but
a lot of the scenes are shorter like
because they're they they trim like that
whole thing with the the spitting in the
water thing like that goes on oh my God
don't don't that's a way longer scene
and um and that so I would kind of be oh
this is like a much shorter version like
I would just I would notice these things
where I'm like this is going on way
shorter and and so I wonder if that had
something to do with my impact
specifically with cely because I didn't
feel that way with um Harpo with Harpo
and uh Daniel Brooks I didn't feel that
way with her uh Coleman Domingo I wasn't
like he does a very something very
different than what Danny Glover did
actually and and so I was able to really
just accept a lot of these performances
on their own merits yet with cely I I I
was like C's the one who like broke me
in in uh in in the on last that's how I
felt in this I was very much connected
to and I never seen like a great other
than ghost you know like I've never seen
like that many whoopy Goldberg
performances and so I was like wow she
is shockingly great in this movie and
that was the hurdle that being said I
still think she was excellent ENT in
this film I still think Fantasia was
excellent here and um her musical
numbers were strong and when she's like
saying I am beautiful I'm like wow that
that really got me thinking you know
like that's that's a hard I'm not I've
been told by many a therapist to be like
you should like learn to say a couple of
nice things to yourself in the mirror
affirmations well one of the few things
I still like I just don't do it is so
hard for me to like get to a point to
like say something was cool yeah I
thought that was like you should do that
do you do
it I don't think I have a problem loving
myself
wow maybe you should reconsider
that yeah see that doesn't hurt me
because I love
me I may you Roxy yeah do you know who
you are don't know listen I came from
therapy today maybe that's why I'm more
in touch with my emotions
today all right I gotta get Roxy out of
here um guys what do you think of this
color purple movie I loved it that was
one of my favorite that the color purple
I was hoping you would you would be able
to answer that well there was two movies
now and I'm like there's that one moment
where we're walking through and taji is
like you know the colors the bright
colors whatever
but other than that but maybe that is
just what it is about I think when I I
think in the other movie I remembered
understanding it better but for some
reason I kind of lost sight of why it's
called The Color Purple
here but it's not really about the color
purple or is it and we totally missed
the point what your favorite color there
was something about whatever the purple
represented here um amongst the
uh I I don't know something deep
purple's
Royal do you want to look it up really
quick then you can go I I I would like
to know now yeah how do I do it my phone
I'll do it oh everyone be quiet yeah
stop talking just like I did during the
yeah why is the color purple called The
Color
Purple
I'm starting to feel a little better
Greg it's because we talked about it
yeah it usually does help and also
because I'm
beautiful anyway let's look this
up you're a nice human being
cor you is smart you is kind you is
important all right what's it telling
you it's telling me uh that I'm
definitely on an ad right now that I got
caught up in
um okay the Toler first
Avery
uh remember God is neither here loves us
different way I think it pisses God off
and if we walk by the color why does he
keep logging
out I'm sorry oh it's sayz I'm on
airplane mode I think to piss God off if
you walk by The Color Purple in a field
somewhere and you don't notice it oh
that's what she Su was saying in the
yeah yeah she has never observed things
that sub Mission changes her life and
hours
mhhh the things that are like staring
you right been she talking about it God
isn't this God isn't that yeah yeah yeah
this honestly because you know I'm not
religious the god stuff didn't impact me
as much but I loved it the keeping like
Hope and Faith did yeah no I I'm I'm the
same way I can watch I'm not religious
but I I do get affected when I see if
it's for a character if it like there's
a sense of community or or what it does
for them if it makes them a better
person in a movie or something like that
like I can watch things like and I could
be very moved by I'm not going to become
like a God-fearing man or something but
I
will I can still be very much moved you
think you're ever going to give me a
comedy we just watch
saltburn that was tough that's hilarious
we
watch we we don't watch heavy films
usually you make me watch the freakiest
horror movies and this was the most
scary or I thought we were going to take
a light break here I was like here's
another
trolls I was like oh my God she's really
sad no I'm glad I watched it's obviously
an amazing movie definitely one of the
best of 2023 for sure absolutely
absolutely guys go watch always Lola if
you want to feel really good about
yourself and uh a like subscribe and hey
you got a hole in your sock I
know and she still thinks she's
beautiful really do on the
inside Landon Miller London welcome to
your shout out my friend is this first
one you must have upgraded yeah look out
it's time for a classic shout
out you're going to regret this oh
you're gonna hate
this so what we like to do is take your
name figure out the acronym him for it m
and I'm just going to say what comes to
mind L stands for licking my butthole oh
yes it
does
a stands
for anal
retentive which I'm sure you are not n
stands for nice guy yes d stands for the
a d which I'm sure you're slinging all
around t o w n oh stands for the shape
of your mouth when you're by my
anus glad one of us had to get there and
and n stands for nuts where uh I'm sure
you've got huge ones man just just like
the craziest craziest nuts craziest nuts
man D's Nuts don't even come close well
come this far M stand stand
for um martyr oh sure because he would
still be willing to die in the good
reject name even if it meant
us you know doing what we're doing right
now yes
exactly uh I stands for um
industrious as I'm sure you are an
enterprising and and you know and
creative human being L stands for the
qucious
is that even a
word the world may never know is just
something Greg thought of could be maybe
you arrived at it independent is that
the definition of
liqua the other L stands for uh
lugubrious what does it mean comment if
you're actually watching the shout out
with the definition so that I can commit
it to memory he stands for
Eternal because you will forever
be laying down with my fa my butt on
your
face yes and I think it only would be
appropriate that R stands for [__] as
you know that will bring no we had to
come full circle in the shout out you
know there's the only one it could be
anything though you maybe you're just uh
you know doing a rim shot on your drums
there maybe that's your version of
riming or maybe uh it's just polishing
up the rims on your car it doesn't have
to be gross man I just wanted to say you
know we've done the first patron of the
month shout outs kind of deal for people
so many times it comes to the acronyms
and really just wanted
to experiment here and make sure you
were loyal enough cuz that's really what
the L stands for in your name oh double
dose of loyalty did it's a test of
loyalty he's got so many l to see if you
would still be willing to stay pledged
in spite this is a test of this shout
out this is a test you just got Landon
Miller look out I hope you're
happy I hope you're satisfied I am
drafting an
apology Dearest
Landon tomorrow morning my dearest
bro we're all friends here right it's
satire thanks Landon Miller we
appreciate
[Music]
you